I became associated with see far because  I began to appreciate what an enormous  asset it was for Canada as a whole I  learned something every day through CFR  and I am also constantly encouraged by  the enthusiasm and dynamism and passion  of the people engaged with this  organization both from a research  perspective and a management perspective  and an overall governance perspective  we've substantially broadened our base  of support over the years in the early  years had a strong legion of  corporations who backed the work that we  were doing a bunch of very much forward  thinking organizations we have over the  course of the last 10 years or so added  a great number of foundation supporters  but we've also added a lot of individual  supporters who in many cases are just  intrigued by the model and of how we  conduct our research and by the  potential possibilities in terms of  discoveries from the questions we're  pursuing so I'm very very excited for  for the future for see farm